Montell Jordan kicking off the morning
medium oval Russell Simmons co-founded
Def Jam Records in 1984
it's the label behind artists like LL
Cool J The Beastie Boys and jay-z
throughout his career Simmons has also
served as a philanthropist for the Arts
now he's the executive producer of the
new documentary Romeo is bleeding the
film follows Dante Clarke he uses spoken
word poetry to share his experiences
from Richmond California Russell Simmons
joins us at the table powerful just
watching that and welcome back to the
show what attracted you most to Dante
story I'm sure you're presented with so
many stories you know the story mirrors
so many others with people who take the
arts and survived because of him and you
know comes from a very difficult place
his brother was killed during to making
the film I mean he had such struggle
that he lived it but yet he transcended
it through his poetry and this movie he
became a teacher and now an activist you
know where he could have been a drug
dealer his aspiration was to be the
biggest drug dealer in Richmond
California and so many kids have been
murdered he created the Romeo and Juliet
scenario over which I mean it's been
told many many times yeah but it's a
timeless tale and it's called Romeo
depleting and he really and the
filmmaker Jason's eldest made an amazing
picture spoken words making a comeback
yes
yeah reflected how you know the rapper's
you know what a music goes away they get
to dig even deeper the artists always
expressed you know their time capsules
that they're poetry's of where they come
from and yet to really understand their
environment and America and you know
doesn't see itself the way they see the
truth you know and I think it's
important that artists do that so spoken
word is a way that the rappers or the
artists from hip hop's
express themselves without music and
neon here and you can hear what they're
saying so you can dig deeper through
spoken word than you can through the
music well I think it's in most cases
you're forced to you know it's silence
you're operating from stillness and
that's isn't that what all of us the
stillness seconds are the only seconds
where we see what's in front of us it
you know we're just talking about
unconscious behavior I mean when you
really silent you can see more and Jason
Jason and what they captured with Dante
is phenomenal this movie will make you
cry talk about the role that education
and and encapsulate in this the lives of
Dante and those around him the positive
side of it that nurtures people for the
better as opposed to being the best drug
dealer in town well when you look inside
you want to be more you know you get all
of the what's in scripture taught to you
over and over again that stuff is inside
you and it rings a bell and you you look
inside so that's that's the idea to
journey inward is life's journey isn't
it I'm if you don't know to self they
say you know everything so that's
something that spoken word and art helps
people to achieve a quicker look inside
because you all get to know it but you
get to know it quicker what's happening
to Kanye West I haven't spoken to him in
a bit if anything else happened no no
I'm just wondering because you know you
know all the people that have have been
in in rap and they were very talented
ups and downs I'll just go through it
you know artists always you know the
sensitive people are you gonna are you
negotiating and hoping that chance will
come in and oh poor thing yeah I kind of
leaked that I mean there's a discussion
I expect it to happen there's a lot of
great inning there's a lot of great
artists now coming or what spoken word
artists who could host it I'm excited to
do Def Poetry it's timing it's good and
I would love the chance to do it then
we're talking to him and you know he
explained to me and he got gave me the
idea to read to look at it again you
know we're shooting Def Comedy again in
about six weeks and that's you know
there's a lack of real insight into
where all that comedy come from and who
they are the artists
so doing that again for HBO now it's fun
to bring that back yeah it's fun because
there's so many eyes that need it I
can't believe how many underserved
artists there are who like you know they
have chocolate sundae and more better
Monday and wild Wednesday they have
segregated sad they didn't call it that
no it's very segregated and the great
comedians and poets don't get to express
themselves and so that's my job I guess
Russell what do you do best what do you
think your best talent is my best talent
that's right that's a tough one I don't
really but is it is it a sense of
marketing and promotion that you have I
like naked genius for that I like to
give what I love you know as an
entrepreneur what I'm doing it all deaf
digital it's like these kids it's 70
kids every day I come to work for them
and I like to give people what I love it
that's my entrepreneurial things was
financial service idea what's my idea
like I loved it and I feel that way
about a lot of things thank you for
coming thank you very much thank you
Romeo is bleeding hits theatres in New
York Wednesday and will expend other
cities July 28th